[Music]
exotic beaches and natural wonders sri
lanka has long dreamt of a place among
the world's top holiday destinations
but terrorist attacks in 2019 rocked the
island nation
then came the pandemic shattering the
tourism industry
while pushing many who depend on it into
poverty
the collapse caused an economic
emergency sri lanka was running out of
money
now its borders are open again
vaccinated tourists can return
sri lanka needs to revive tourism but is
that possible in a pandemic
hi i'm ben fazoulen good to have you
with us the long wait is over for sri
lanka those tourism dollars are flowing
again no need for quarantine if you're
fully vaccinated and the government's
giving frontline workers and those in
the tourism industry booster shots
against covet
they're among the first guests back at
the surf camp in southern sri lanka
alexander and carolyn have come from
germany
they have waited for a long time to go
surfing again
their coach gives them some final
instructions before they hit the waves
after 18 months of the pandemic the surf
camp set out a newsletter hoping to
attract surfers back to sri lanka
and it worked
the hope is that they will attract other
tourists back to the country as well
during the pandemic we missed being able
to travel and so as soon as countries
open up again the surfers will be back
nearby those suffering from stress can
come to relax this ayurveda hotel is
very popular with german visitors the
tour operator emphasizes the freedom of
movement in sri lanka all you need is a
negative test or proof of vaccination
is this absolute
there is no need for quarantine any
longer
tourists can come to sri lanka and move
around freely from day one
they can leave ayurveda resort there's
the 14-day ayurveda treatment course
but otherwise they're completely free to
visit national parks for example
the hotel is fully booked the manager of
this german agency specializing in
ayurveda breaks is happy he hopes that
tourists will continue to come to the
island
neil washington has had some short
nights lately but he doesn't mind his
travel agency doesn't just welcome
surfers many other international guests
are returning 12 000 since september
last night i had to go because there are
a lot of tourists coming i have to
regroup the drivers to pick up them
around the transport and welcome them
from the airport so i had to go to
colombo and i'd come back now
the surf camp has been able to open
again but many other hotels and resorts
haven't survived the pandemic
it was very difficult because it was all
down it was
down to the ashes because
everything was closed and there were no
tourism
so the p the tourist branch has affected
very much
and joining me now two experts on
tourism manoj samaratunga in colombo at
a more global perspective from freyja
higgins stabile in australia thanks for
joining us both of you um manoj can we
begin with you can you give us your
assessment did uh sri lanka or how sri
lanka got it right in in tackling this
crisis in supporting its tourism
industry how far it's gone and in
reopening
yeah thank you very much ben and thank
you very much uh deutsche weller for
inviting me to join with you today and
thank you very much for selecting sri
lanka in particular to talk about how we
are
recovering from the from the two
nightmares the easter sunday attack and
the kovit 19 pandemic and now we are
happy to say that with the boost
with the guidelines of the world health
organizations and the ministry of health
we have successfully combat
the the spread of the kobe 19
disease in sri lanka however the risk is
still there and we have prepared our
hotel staff and the airline staff and
restaurant and to guide travel agencies
on how to proceed with the new normal
situations and fortunate for us now we
have seen the green light and many
tourists have started visiting sri lanka
with their uh the vaccination cards or
if they find
if they come with a negative
certification of of the pcr test of
course they can visit their pristine or
preferred hotels without any uh
obstacles from the authorities okay so
you say the risk is still there freya
can you chime in is is it too risky to
reopen right now for sri lanka
well all the countries in the world are
trying to find that right balance
between public health and getting the
economy back and running a country like
sri lanka will be at an advantage if
it's one of the early openers and i know
that the maldives has opened as well
so
we all have to try
to find the way to open properly and
then invite tourists and particularly
there's an appetite for
international travel because many of us
have been locked down and having
difficulties in travel
so you know there's a chance to take
advantage of that really strong urge to
travel what some people are calling
revenge travel which is that really
strong desire to get out there so i
think sri lanka is modeling the way and
we can see how it plays out
minaj
what do you think about
the risk of tourists bringing back
covert or or a more deadly strain of
covert into your country
it's an important question then actually
we started bubble tourism many months
back with a ukrainian tourists and we
had our lessons right and we learned
them very much and now that we have
trained as i mentioned earlier we have
trained our staff we have certified the
hotels according to the health and
safety standards that they are
maintaining
the tourists will also bring certain uh
maybe they might be contagious but still
they will go through the health and
safety protocols and because since we
are following the strict health
guidelines imposed by the world health
organization and the minister of
health
and i think we will be able to overcome
the challenges and the risks that come
up with the tourism the other question i
have for you is do you really want all
those tourists back
i know in some parts of the world it's a
case of
tourism not being
sustainable for the environment or for
the country itself
of course ben and tourism been a very
much
sensitive industry to the environmental
changes cultural changes and and and the
economic changes and uh
we need the food is badly because we
know uh we all know that sri lanka is a
developing country and we do not have
that many foreign exchange in our pocket
remaining right now and the three main
foreign exchange earners in sri lankan
economy are the workers remittance and
the textiles and apparent apparel and
the number three is tourism and tourism
in particular contributes to the 13 of
the foreign exchange earnings and that
have dropped to zero level during the
last year and
and on the other hand not to mention the
our foreign workers about 100 out of
300 000 maybe one quarter have returned
home and many of the micro and small
scale and the medium scale garments have
been shut down so there's no way of
earning extra foreign exchange for in
currency back to sri lanka so we have
identified tourism is the easiest way to
bring the dollars back to sri lanka
bring the euros back to sri lanka and
that's why we are strict between the
health advisors of the wh and expecting
to have more the country can i just ask
freya one question before uh we leave it
what about a more responsible tourism uh
and more sustainable tourism industry
and and one that also welcomes vaccine
equity
i think it's really important that we
learn lessons from the covert shutdown
so for a country like sri lanka and for
visitors that are coming from europe to
countries like sri lanka i think we need
to look at how do we create forms of
tourism that really spend money in the
local economy and support local
well-being
after kobe we are going to find that the
big multinationals are going to come out
of this better than small to medium
enterprises and micro enterprises so i
hope that uh countries like sri lanka
think about getting a really sound mix
and not being overly tourism dependent
and particularly on international
visitors and that tourists think about
their choices when they travel
and this issue of vaccine equity is
there that we'd all be in a lot better
position if we had looked as a global
community to take care of developing
countries countries of the global south
like sri lanka so that we have equal
access to the vaccines and better
coverage so as we go into the future
we've got cop26 happening and the
threats of climate change we are going
to have future crises i think we should
look at the pandemic and ask ourselves
how have we formed a global community
where we take care of each other and
that's how tourism thrives tourism
thrives in countries that are safe that
are healthy that have good well-being
that's how tourists are welcomed and
we'd all do better with that kind of
situation
frankie
thank you to both of you for joining us
today on dw
thank you ben thank you
another viewer question now from derek
williams and this one on susceptibility
to the coronavirus
is everyone equally susceptible to
covid19
well obviously people who are vaccinated
or who have recovered from a previous
infection with sargasso b2
they'll be much less susceptible to
infection or re-infection than someone
who's unvaccinated or or someone who has
never been exposed
new evidence actually indicates that
vaccines do an even better job of
protecting you
than a previous infection does at least
in the short to medium term and at least
against the current variants
where things get interesting though is
when you start looking at whether some
people might be naturally immune to
soros cov2
from the get-go because of their genes
researchers have discovered genetic
mutations in some people
that make them resistant to other
diseases like malaria or hiv
they just don't get them could there be
a similar group of people out there who
can't get covet 19
an international team of researchers has
now begun
looking for those people um one
promising source of data could for
instance come from households
where everyone
got coveted 19 except for one person
despite extensive exposure how come
was it just coincidence or or did they
maybe have a genetic mutation
that protected them in some way
hundreds of people who didn't contract
the disease even though
common sense says that they should have
they've already volunteered for the
study um actually
identifying natural resistance if it
exists will be very challenging but but
experts say that the search is really
worth it first
because it would tell us much more about
exactly how the virus infects us and and
maybe why
some people get it so much worse than
others and and second
because the knowledge could provide
really a huge foot up
in developing new therapies as it
already has for instance with hiv
[Music]
stay safe and see you again soon
[Music]
you